this video is brought to you by keeps
what's up wisecrack Michael here I have
a confession to make about the team here
at wisecrack we're obsessed with Cults
documentaries about cults even more so
now to be clear we have no interest in
joining one as they are usually very bad
and cause lots of psychological and
often physical harm to people so it's
probably no surprise that we've been
mainlanding episodes of The Vowel the
recent series exploring a cult called
Nexium and its Judo champion at 11
figurehead Keith renere who sucks and
was just sentenced to a 120 years behind
bars for some truly horrific crimes for
the uninitiated Nexium is one part
multi-level marketing scheme where you
pay thousands of dollars to take
leadership classes in hotel conference
rooms and five parts a cult where people
wear different colored sashes and
sometimes branded themselves with Keith
Renee's initials before sleeping with
them now this all grabbed my attention
because people like to call renere a
philosopher I have as my mentor an
American scientist and philosopher by
the name of Keith Ranieri and according
to the university that gave me a PhD in
the people who published my book I am
too no Judo skills though I was pretty
good at volleyball in high school so
join me as I suspend my critical
judgment and see what this smartest man
alive has to say and maybe in the
process we can figure out how a great
big creep convinced everyone to mutilate
themselves for the love of knowledge
let's go
and before we get into it I want to give
a shout out to keeps I personally love
my style I love my hat collection and my
sneakers some people love to do their
makeup or sport their Supreme drip
others love styling their hair and if
that's you then I could totally see why
losing your hair might seem like the end
of the world I wouldn't Panic though
because you can combat hair loss and the
sooner you take action the more hair you
can keep keeps is an affordable hair
loss treatment plan that brings FDA
approved prescriptions and
over-the-counter medication right to
your door it's so simple and easy you
can complete all the steps online from
the comfort of your own home you'll
visit a virtual doctor and the
medication will be shipped straight to
you if you're noticing that you're
losing hair and aren't ready to rock the
bald look then check out keeps today
with keep some men even experience hair
regrowth so give it a go for a limited
time go to keeps.com wisecrack or click
the link in the description to receive
50 off your first order now back to the
show
there's no problem with the planet it's
the stuff we do you will be as ethical
as possible you will be that which you
want to see in the world
oh says the grown man in the white sash
so this sounds straightforward enough if
a little vague the thing that comes up
again and again is that renery has this
cool new form of ethics and it's going
to transform the world many of his
followers refer to him as I guess she
made a turn I've ever met but
superlatives aside what does that even
mean luckily philosophers love defining
terms most broadly ethics defines good
and bad behavior for the ancient Greeks
like Plato or Aristotle this meant
living a virtuous life for your more
modern utilitarian theorist it's the
idea that we should take actions that
will bring the most amount of Happiness
to the most amount of people another big
player deontology argues that any good
act must be applied universally there's
no exceptions like uh lion is bad except
for when I'm lying to save a loved one
from a murderer and of course there's
someone like novelist iron Rand who
thought the pursuit of one's individual
happiness was the only truly ethical
position a lot of it is the philosophy
of objectivism which is Ein Rand there
it is renery shares Ran's individualist
vision for the world but I don't think
reading The Fountainhead makes you the
CEO of Ethics any more than reading The
Old Man and the Sea qualifies you to
join the cast of Deadliest Catch
we should be building ethicists people
are going to elect Ephesus to be
president
now if we're going for people who pursue
their own happiness should run Society
well this basically already exists in
the form of every venture capitalist and
Karen at a Starbucks also if we're going
for plagiarized Ein Rand there's plenty
of people in elected office who already
espouse her views so not much to see
here an act of character you feel all
those emotions and there's a part of you
that is unflappable
absolutely committed
okay finally getting a little more
specific now this isn't a brand new idea
for example philosopher Emmanuel Kant
thought any real ethical act had to be
disconnected from emotions so it's not
about feeling like something is the
right thing to do it's about knowing
something is the right thing to do even
if you absolutely do not feel like doing
it and to an extent this seems to be
what renery is getting at but the
crucial difference is that for Kant
these ethical acts have to be grounded
in the principle of humanity meaning
that we never use human beings as fodder
for some bigger goal so uh we're still
saying it's a no-go on sex slaves but
civilization people working together
based on principle
to improve the nature of existence
itself it's the worst summer camp ever
but there's nothing too controversial
here Sigmund Freud the guy who made you
feel creepy for loving your mother might
say that Civilization helps us shove our
instinctual desires into a deep pit so
we can make the society loving part of
our brain happy and other philosophers
like Jean-Jacques Rousseau thought that
the nature of human civilization was
putting the strengths of individuals
together to collectively achieve greater
things so renari's definition is both
uncontroversial and kind of boring all
right what's next is that definition of
Hell which has come to love
which is Oh I thought you know the
definition of hell is
you on the day that you're going to die
how you are meeting the you you could
have been
that's a really good one it is they say
philosophy begins in condescension but
unlike handing out colorful sashes to
your underlings this is actually a cool
idea it's also something most first-year
philosophy students would recognize as
not very original Friedrich Nietzsche
who didn't even know what volleyball was
described something like this as a love
of Fate basically he imagined living
your life on repeat Groundhog Day style
to the end of Eternity if that sounds
like a bummer you're probably not stoked
on your life choices or on the prospect
of repeating them forever but if you
truly embrace your life and your actions
you might be stoked to do it all over
again and again and again renery's idea
is just a rhetorical twist instead of
pondering whether you're going to suffer
eternally as you relive your choices you
instead just get to meet the person who
made the best version of themselves so I
mean sure but both Bill Murray and
Nietzsche said it better moving on it is
true for you so therefore it is true to
some degree
for me this looks like he's really
getting into the philosophy of why you
never never question me and it's
interesting as renere is veering into
the territory of what we call
post-modernism or perspectivism these
theorists argue that there is no such
thing as fixed or objective truth but
the truth is dependent on our experience
and perspective and that different
individuals could have different
experiences of the same events this idea
has been explored by Nisha Jacques
derida and John Francois leotard to
Advocate that we be skeptical about just
how amazing an all-knowing human beings
can actually be people in this Camp to
varying degrees argue that there is no
one objective truth that transcends
culture context or perspective but this
doesn't mean whatever is true for me is
my truth you dig instead it means that
we need to be humble enough to
acknowledge that different people will
have different perspectives imbued with
their own biases even when experiencing
the same event text or discount Faye of
course for context here renery is using
this idea to Gaslight a group of women
carefully expressing their concerns
about his behavior and that's absolutely
not cool so abuse is is a made-up human
construct and a lot of times the
screaming of abuse is abuse in itself
so we can just say it now right this
guy's just a piece of [ __ ] I think we
can just say it you guys see it I see it
we can we can save okay so what he's
doing here is playing Mad Libs with
postmodern language for philosophers
like Daria post-modernism was a way to
rethink how certain we can really be
about human knowledge it was not a way
to tell people they were wrong for
feeling abused or victimized rhaenery is
peddling in exactly the type of [ __ ]
that post-modernism has been criticized
for by those who frankly didn't read the
books so what else does judo man have
for us the Primitive parts of us are
hungry beasties I mean that's what we
want to do okay
um I almost don't want to give this idea
the time of day but he seems to be
veering into the realm of someone like
Thomas Hobbs who thought the human state
of nature is one of all-out War where we
do whatever we can to eat screw and
survive however philosophers ranging
from Plato to Aristotle to Kant to
contemporary figures like a long bed you
have argued that to think of ourselves
is crass animals is to miss what makes
humans interesting namely our capacity
for reason and our ability to seek truth
Kant says that if we were just meant to
eat sleep and screw then nature did a
shitty job at designing us because we're
also neurotic and curious and anxious
and reflective all things that don't
really help our animal survival even
primatologists who study the behavior of
primates gorillas and stuff reject the
idea that primates are just murderous
violent freaks there's plenty of
evidence that our thumbless cousins also
work together and have hot consensual
relations so Kant actual scientists and
many others would say that rhaenerys
over identification of humans with
primitive beasties is woefully
inadequate it also creates a dangerous
Paradigm in which people can do really
bad things and justify it because
they're just hungry beasties
okay we're almost done but we have one
more gem to consider okay I I wrote a
fable once that started that there was a
mighty king that took over a culture wow
dude wrote a fable
and this King used torture and fear to
create obedience hmm
sounds kind of like a co-leader who
collects blackmail on his followers
and over time people found that if they
just obeyed what the king said there was
peace across the land
but what they sacrificed for that was
their Traditions their customs and all
of their identity
the threat of violence was enough to
keep social order
but if the king went and killed everyone
then he would have to do all the work so
the people who are being victimized have
a certain power and they can stand
against the king okay
um where to begin with this one first of
all he didn't write a fable once he used
as much ASAP as he is not a sociopath
the basic gist here is powerful people
use that power to Lord over others but
they often need the powerless to
maintain their own power not in original
or new or special or interesting idea
but philosophically it's a watered-down
version of hegel's Master Slave
dialectic which is a fable that explains
the structure of human consciousness and
also everything else for Hegel the
master Lords over his slaves to feel
powerful and their recognition of him as
the master confirms this feeling but
eventually the slaves realize that they
actually do a lot more than their master
and that without them he's basically
useless and the master realizes that
he's actually dependent it on them to
feel all powerful and special so voila
we have a reversal of power now for
Hegel this explains a concept called
Mutual recognition where both sides
realize their Mutual interdependence for
renery this means that um if everyone in
his cult locked out he'd be left
powerless but they haven't so
everything's chill okay so what have we
learned by suspending our judgment to
momentarily consider the philosophy of a
real life piece of [ __ ] well renari's
modus operandi seems pretty simple step
one take some relatively basic
uncontroversial ideas step two rephrase
them to make yourself sound smart and
original and step three use these
original ideas to justify your sadistic
and manipulative agenda and convince
your followers to do stuff like sever
ties with their loved ones and enter
into Master Slave relationships with
their friends interrogating the
tradition for insights and how to live a
good and virtuous life this is not well
that's it for our philosophical journey
into the mind of a sociopathic cult
leader and hopefully this is a good
reminder that if someone is trying to
get you to pay lots of money to join
their philosophical movement you should
run as fast as you can in the opposite
direction and never look back seriously
if a philosophical education is what you
seek simply visit your local library we
mentioned books all the time in our
videos so go check them out and please
let us know what you think of this new
format in the comments we just wanted to
try something fun which is something we
all need these days right huge thanks to
our patrons for your support hit that
subscribe button like it's the lever
that keeps your train from going
anywhere near Albany and as always
thanks for watching later
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]